hello everyone and welcome to game four
or rather the final game of day one of
the finals between wesley saw and magnus
crossing in the skilling open
and uh before i show you game four i
just want to show you briefly what
happened in game two so game one we
already saw that
um magnus won a very nice game but this
is uh
sorry not this actually this uh you've
seen nothing uh this
is the the sort of ending position of
game two where wesley so had the white
pieces magnus is black here
and wesley gave a check here queen e3
check and magnus either has to block the
check or move the king uh
to the uh well towards the queen side
king the eighth queen this uh
king d7 however magnus played king to f8
here and he ran
into an un uh most unpleasant
checkmating sequence
uh where wesley played queen e8 check
sorry about that
uh we have king to g7 and now a nice
roller coaster uh queen
queen g8 check king h6 quinta
h7 check uh king to g5 and now queen to
h5
check and then it was in this position
that magnus carlsen resigned the game
because he realized that after king
moves to f4
uh queen to f5 will be checkmate because
the king and the pawn
cover all of the squares that the black
king can go to
so it was a terrible blunder by magnus
uh it was an incredible game first
wesley was uh
really pushing it for the wind and
magnus sort of equalized but then magnus
no longer wanted the draw
he wanted to win the game and then he
started pushing and then
in the end where it kind of was supposed
to end in a draw
magnus blundered in this uh well weird
weird position
after this uh check by wesley so then
uh that's uh game two wesley equalized
in game two
then magnus was able to win in game
three was a rather short game magnus
attacked very early on on the king side
and uh was able to take the win and now
it's two to one in magnus's favor
uh he needs uh uh either hold this game
to a draw or win the game uh to win the
final match so this is a game four
uh wesley is losing by one point margin
he needs a win to get back into the
match
so let's see what happens wesley with
the white pieces opens with
e4 we have c5 by magnus
magnus when whenever there is an
important game he can always rely on his
sicilian he used it very
uh successfully against fabiano caruana
in the world chess championship match so
knight f3 knight to c6 and the d4 we
have the open sicilian
captures captures and now knight to f6
we have knights the c3 and the e5 the
so-called lasker uh sicilian
or the pelican or or the swesnikov uh so
challenging the knight uh
knight d to b5 and now d6 so this is the
exact same stuff that was played in the
world chess championship match
knight d5 uh going for that c7 square
and now of course black trace captures
captures
and now the two popular replies are
knight b8 and knight to e7 magnus
chooses to go to b8
and here white usually goes c4 a4
uh just uh uh these are the most popular
popular replies but here wesley goes for
queen to f3
which is not a new move but it is uh it
is a very sneaky idea and it's played a
lot
less often for example in 2020 there is
not a single game
uh where this move was used so he he
uh probably prepared for for magnus this
game with a6 by magnus
challenging this knight and now queen to
a3 so very nice maneuver queen f3 queen
to a3
saying that okay if you capture this
night then i'm gonna grab your rook
uh and it's not uh again this is not a
new move there are over there are 65
games in the database uh
from top tier players that reach this
position
so uh we have knight uh sorry b6 by
magnus
uh bishop to e7 is more common than b6
as you want to
castle very early on so bishop to g5 by
wesley
challenging the queen offering a bishop
to go for this knight the c7 church so
magnus of course cannot accept it
and after this we have bishop to e7 and
bishop to e7 is the new move by magnus
so as of movie 11 we have a completely
new game
and bishop to e7 is not the most precise
idea f6 is what is usually played in
this position
uh but i i imagine wesley caught magnus
by surprise with this queen to f3
a queen to a3 idea so like i said bishop
to e7 was played and now
wesley just captures it captures and now
you cannot capture with the queen
because the knight captures with
check and black's position is just
terrible
if not outright losing because you have
a past pawn here you can
just do pretty much anything there's not
not a good reply here
for for black so instead we have king
captures on e7 now the d6 pawn is
guarded twice so everything is fine and
now
queen side castle by wesley uh bishop to
b7 the knight still cannot be captured
because the rook is hanging so bishop to
b7
defends the rook and attacks the pawn so
now the knight can be captured
and only now wesley moves it back knight
to c3
and now knight to d7 magnus is now ready
to bring the knight into the game
via c5 or f6 squares and
f4 by wesley carlson's king is still in
the center of the board and of course he
wants to bust open the position
and here magnus plays the very calm
queen to c7 just keeping an eye on the
center and
connecting rooks at some point uh if
he's able he wants to play uh
well i'll get the rook into the game and
hopefully get the king to safety
uh but uh he cannot do it just yet
because if
this pawn is not guarded then you will
never be able to move it
so queen c7 also guards the d6 pawn and
now
f captures an e5 we have knight captures
on e5
and now queen to b4 queen to be for a
very tricky idea by wesley
saying okay if you go rook h to 28 and
castle i'm just going to deliver check
queen h4 check and i'm going to pick up
the h7 pawn and it's going to be a
terrible position for black
so after queen b4 we have h5 by magnus
saying okay i'm i'm probably not
castling this game i might as well uh
grab some space on the king side with
bishop to e2
and now king to f8 this is how magnus
brings his king back to safety
uh rook h to f1 uh just lining up the
the rook with with the king on the f
file we have rook to e8 magnus brings
the
queen side rook into the game and now
rook to f5
uh putting pressure on this h5 pawn so
magnus pushes it we have
h4 and now rook to f4 again with a
double attack on the pawn here
so queen to d8 uh defending this pawn
and now this queen is uh
in in a terrible position the queen has
to guard this pawn has to guard this
pawn has to guard this pawn
it's not another very pleasant job for
the queen so here uh wesley doesn't
rush it with something like rook d to f1
instead he plays the nice prophylactic
king b1
as it's always nice to have a save king
and he says you you don't really have a
move here magnus i can play whatever i
want
so here rook to h6 this is how magnus
activates the rook now also adds a
defender to the d6 pawn and it's gonna
be a bit easier to play
and wesley doesn't double up on the f
file which seems like a reasonable thing
to do rather he plays
rook d to d4 and uh as
someone mentioned i don't know where uh
he points the idiot his gun
in in the wrong direction now he's going
after the h4 pawn
and now uh magnus pushes it to the h3 so
of course he's hoping for a character's
captures
uh to gain some activity along the h
file but wesley just says nope
g3 and the next i might play something
like this and
uh well i will win that pawn at some
point so here
bishop to c8 magnus defends it not not
allowing any such ideas
and a4 now it's uh remarkable how it's a
pretty crazy position but wesley finds
time to play such uh you know
just improving his position moves king
to g8
getting the king away from the from the
f file and now comes
rook d to e4 and
what do you play now if you move the
knight and then wesley can just capture
you have to capture and then your entire
position falls apart
uh not that one obviously uh and here
magnus play the queen to c7
so again wha what do you play here uh
here wesley played rook to h4 which was
the original idea
threatening the rook and then the other
rook can come up to the game and gobble
up the pawn so here we have
a5 challenging wesley's queen and the
queen to d4
uh centralizing the queen but not not
really
uh for the moment the queen doesn't
really have all that much to do here
but magnus has to react to this and you
you don't really have a good move other
than capturing the rook you can't really
allow captures to mess up your
king side so rook captures an h4 we have
rook captures on h4 and now comes
bishop to f5 by magnus putting pressure
on the c2 pawn if the knight ever moves
there was a very sneaky queen to c5 idea
um similar to the to the queen move that
nipple had against magnus you offer a
queen trade and
then the queen trade uh either should be
accepted or if wesley moves the queen
then you you can infiltrate for example
with queen to f2
and now it's uh it's a a little bit
easier to play this
uh but okay magnus one went for uh
bishop to f5
he puts pressure on the spawn here and
now wesley goes
rook to h5 challenges the bishop and now
you don't really have a good square for
the bishop you could go just bishop g6
then
just a rook captures an h3 as the bishop
no longer defends it
or you could go back you can't go here
you can't go here this is all defended
twice
you could go something like here but
then you're going to have to give up the
bishop either way because after knight
b5 the bishop
has to be traded for knight here because
if you don't if you
move the queen to kind of keep an eye on
everything then g4 and then the the h3
pawn is again
no longer defended you're just going to
capture it and it's going to be a
very very good position for white so
instead after this
rook to h5 move we have queen to c8 by
magnus defends the bishop
but now queen captures on b6 and here
why did magnus give up upon here well
he decided to go knight to g4 so he
basically said to wesley you cannot
capture that pawn because it's defended
by a tactic now your bishop is under
attack
and well if i capture the bishop for
example if wesley plays something like
queen captures on a5 magnus would
just capture the bishop and after the
knight captures now the queen can
finally capture here and then it's
either a win for magnus if wesley plays
something weird like king day one and
allows checkmate
or if king a2 then magnus would have a
draw by perpetual for example queen a1
check you don't want to go too much up
the board
so king to b3 again queen d1 check king
a2
and of course not capturing but rather
just going queen to b1 check and
repeating everything
because magnus only needs a draw to win
this to win this match
uh but this is what magnus thought would
happen however there's a very sneaky
idea here so feel free to pause the
video and find
the winning move for wesley while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on
combining combining the two ideas this
is this is being threatened you need to
move it with tempo
so bishop a6 congratulations for all of
you who found it uh
as it's uh well not all that
straightforward move to find
so the queen is under attack and now
you're asking uh magnus what do you want
to do here
your queen is under attack but still
needs to guard the bishop here and the
problem is
uh the problem is if you move the queen
somewhere like a queen to d7
then the problem is bishop to b5 and now
the queen and rook are under attack and
after the queen moves uh for example
here you're either you're gonna capture
the rook
uh and if not if you go for something
like queen to d8 to attack white's queen
then
white very happily trades and after rook
captures on f5
white is just up a piece and it's a very
easy victory
so this is not possible here uh so after
this
bishop to a6 move uh we have uh rook to
e1 with
check this is how magnus tries to avoid
this uh we have king the a2
and the now comes queen to e8 uh the
problem with queen to d7 now keeping an
eye on the bishop is the very unpleasant
rook captures on f5 it's just a
complete domination queen captures an f5
and now queen to d8 with
check and now you don't have a move here
uh because you can either give up the
rook and it's the same scenario or you
can move the king and then bishop goes
back to d3 and
wins carlsen's queen so terrible
terrible position for magnus he decides
to go queen to e8
gives up the dark square bishop and here
wesley just happily gobbles it up rook
captures on f5
and here magnus is just down a piece in
a worse position
and he of course will will still
continue playing it the knights the e3
attacks the rook here but now bishop to
b5 wesley first challenges
magnus's queen queen to e7 and when
magnus played queen to e7 it was also in
this position that
magnus carlsen resigned the game because
there is nothing more to be done here
and there are simply any move wesley
plays is just completely winning you
just move the rook anywhere and
the position is still winning however we
can show uh a sneaky line for example if
rook h5 uh cutting the king off from
from escaping anywhere
and now if black plays a let's say a
lesser move
knight captures on c2 then queen to b8
is winning immediately yeah because
after you block it of course you cannot
block with this because the bishop
covers it and
if let's say if queen of fate then just
rook h8 to check and
this is just completely winning for
white so
uh really really wild stuff wesley gets
back into the game in a must-win
situation so he was
losing by by a point uh going into game
four and now he won on demand so this is
pretty incredible
and here is something funny for you to
see uh there you can see that uh the
players
every every game was won by uh the
player playing with the white pieces so
uh
pretty crazy so not a single draw in
this match and we can only hope that
the second match will be uh just as you
know feisty
uh so that's uh the game uh i do hope
you guys enjoyed it uh
and uh i would like to thank uh ivan
green uh slobodan mercato which
gives sears thomas jones and hoodie guy
for contribution to my channel thank you
a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the scaling open the finals
the last day of the finals
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day